all right so i posed a question early in
the program chris sims good friend
tattoo buddy of kyle shanahan the head
coach of the san francisco 49ers and it
is a very simple question the phone
rings
on the other end there's a guy named tom
brady who wants to have a hypothetical
conversation because free agent hasn't
begun yet they're not allowed to have
those communications but those
communications happen all the time
tom brady reaches out to kyle shanahan
and says kyle
i grew up in northern california i was a
49ers fan i was at the game that became
known forever as the catch game
i would like to finish my career playing
for the 49ers and i believe that i can
help you get over the hump i watched the
super bowl carefully and although i am
reluctant to criticize anyone
specifically i believe i can be the
difference next year given the quality
of the team that you have what say you
kyle and oh by the way you name the
price i don't care about the money i got
money what i want is ring number seven
and i think i can win it with you chris
how can kyle shanahan say no to that
well you know i think he can say no i
think but you know knowing my friend
kyle first off i mean he's he's you know
extremely intelligent so he's not going
to just sit there and you know appease
brady he'll think about it i do think
that i think he'd be smart enough to sit
there digest it talk to john lynch maybe
talk to jed york
i think realistically though he would
come down to okay yeah i bring tom brady
in right uh but my team's a super bowl
team right now does this upset chemistry
you know what can brady really do can he
you know effectively
do some of the plays that i like in my
playbook and i think brady of course
he'll bring plays too to the to the
table that he'll teach shanahan and go
oh i did this in new england and this is
how we taught it these are our rules and
i'm sure kyle would infuse that in there
but i think the big thing ultimately is
you know i just think kyle
is all in on jimmy g
you know they had a great year let's not
forget with where they were and what
they did this year and i think he also
you have to think about mike you know
you get a guy like brady and go okay
yeah i get you for one year maybe two
and then then what where do i go from
cousins okay cousins maybe you're right
i know you said that during commercial
break and you know that's not a crazy
thought yeah okay one year maybe but
what if tom wants to come there and sign
a two-year deal and now you're stuck
with him for two years and kurt was a
free agent kirk was a free agent after
this this year coming up and then but if
he comes to you and says i want to play
for you you say we'll sign you to a
one-year deal that's it we'll do it for
a year we'll try it for a year and then
we'll decide where we're going to go
after that it's that simple he's going
to be 43 right i don't think you make a
multi-year commitment with a guy who's
going to be 43 well i mean i think it's
real but but but look
let's go back to the conversation we had
about why kyle didn't evaluate patrick
mahomes he thought he was getting kirk
cousins a year later right so your plan
could be this is the jimmy garoppolo uh
kind of like what the broncos did with
tim tebow although at a greater scale
because this was actually a super bowl
team and unlike tebow garoppolo is
actually capable of throwing inaccurate
football more than one out of every 10
times but uh
brady for a year and then you bring in
kirk cousins i mean i i was thinking
about this earlier
we're trying to figure out what brady's
going to do i think the answer is hiding
in plain sight the 49ers may not want
him but how could you not want the
greatest player who ever lived how could
you not want to solve the santa clara
traffic problems for every game they
play next year how could you not want to
sell
tens of thousands of tom brady jerseys
once john brody says it's okay to wear
number 12. and you know what he's
already said it was okay for trent
dilfer to wear number 12. if it's okay
for dilfer it's going to be okay for
brady and they're going to make a ton of
money and that's part of this game too
chris
yeah sure it is but you know also could
be part of this game is thinking that
you know i got jimmy garoppolo and this
won't be my last super bowl we will go
to and we're going to make a run and
that'll continue to sell jerseys and
tickets and you know have santa clara
with their traffic problems or whatever
else and like i i know what you mean
when you say like it's hiding in plain
sight yes it's hiding in plain sight go
back to new england where you've won six
super bowls and bid nine to the then
nine of them wait a minute wait a minute
all things considered yeah all things
considered right right you're tom brady
yeah would you rather play for the 49ers
or the patriots next year i would rather
play for the patriots oh crap i would
you know what you're in a again they're
just hey i'm already the man in this
team this locker room i got
relationships with these coaches i know
what to expect i'm gonna be able to run
my offense and not have to adjust and
learn things like that you know i know
the culture here all we got to do really
here is just get me a weapon or two and
things change man a lot of things change
if he goes to the other team apparently
it's harder than it looks because they
failed to do it last year i don't know
why you'd think they would do it this
way because they got antonio brown and
he went crazy that's what they tried
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports